this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you want
to get paid five dollars and also give
five dollars to charity do you want to
buy and sell Bitcoin instantly or get
your paycheck deposited right to the app
well the cash up is the number one
finance app in the App Store
and we'll talk about it more later on in
the show so you guys got to download the
free cash app for iOS or Android 57 of
congratulations temporarily forgot the
name of my own podcast but it's only
been 57 episodes I promise to get it
right
suck one of these days this you guys got
to download my app it's the crystal Lea
app you just type in crystally in the
App Store I can get it on multiple
phones and [ __ ] and you see some behind
the scenes of congratulations you see
some behind the scenes I'm a lifestyle I
go live on there a little bit some of
the time and this episode is the first
episode we've done in studio without the
illustrious
one fire so if this one goes very well
then maybe one actually fire but we got
the one fire to it
filling in doing both one fire one and
one fire two duties so yeah and and the
reason why one fire is out is because
he's out sick and he says he has the flu
which is absolutely not true he doesn't
have the flu he definitely just has some
sort of sickness and is saying it is the
flu how many times do people say oh yeah
I got the flu and really they just have
a sniffly nose and those people what are
they
mark ass [ __ ] but he said he has a
bad coffin didn't want to be coughing in
the background and every time he coughed
me safe on fire so anyway you can get
your one fire shirts
I think there
gone there might be a few left but
they're limited run we're just doing it
for the [ __ ] true babies I got myself
sent one and I wear it around oh by the
way one fire was on vacation over the
past few days and spotted a baby out
with the congratulations hat on and he
pointed to him and said true baby and he
said oh yeah a true baby so it's very
cool oh and the other day I was at a
coffee shop you know I loved it you know
I love going to coffee shops and I saw a
true baby out in the wild he said hey
man I just want to let you know I'm a
true baby and he showed me his phone and
he had a sticker on the he had my
sticker my silhouette on the on the
phone so I said oh it's cool to see a
baby out in the wild so it was very cool
and then that guy tweeted me he's an
actor I won't be able to find it now but
shout-out to that dude good-looking
actor dude let me see if I can find the
tweet here he was his name is Spencer
McPherson hmm so born on June 12th
anyways I don't know why you can say
where you're when you're born on your on
your [ __ ] Twitter but you can so you
know what I've been doing lately is
falling asleep at night waking up at
about 8:00 and then hang in there and
forcing myself to fall asleep again
because why the [ __ ] not I'm on I'm on
my little I'm I'm on some down time
before I start my tour and all that [ __ ]
and those that hour and a half I sleep
more on I sleep more I have the most
vivid terrifying dreams like I'll sleep
for a [ __ ] six hours at night wake up
and I'll be like you know what I'll just
take a little bit more of some sleep and
I do and welcome to hell it's like it's
like I wake up at a beautiful morning I
let's sleep in I don't have too much to
do all I really got to go do is go go
get a coffee and ice and I Zonk back out
and welcome to hell I don't know what it
is I've been listening to the [ __ ]
sword and scale or or true-crime garage
Oh or watching some documentaries or
dude I woke and you know what also it is
to dreams that aren't necessarily
terrifying when you recite them to
somebody like to wake up and you'd be
like dude I had the most terrifying
dream and you're and they're like what
and then you're like I was like I was in
this [ __ ] office space and but it was
like a warehouse and like my boss was
like I'll be right back and then didn't
and then didn't come back for a while
and like they were playing [ __ ] like
these willem dafoe movies on on an on
projector on the side of a wall and
you're like yeah and you're like yeah
and it was like lit weird and you're
like oh that's not terrifying but it
feels terrifying when you're there you
know it feels like it was like The Blair
Witch but I feels like found-footage
like that's what it was like so now when
I try to recite to you my [ __ ] dream
that I had last night and I had a
terrifying one the night before too but
I don't remember it but I remember this
one and I'm gonna tell it to you and
it's gonna be not terrifying and borns
[ __ ] but it's very telling for us babies
so I'm going to tell you guys what the
dream was so woke up at about 8:00 fell
back asleep and in the dream all of a
sudden somebody tells me I don't
remember her but they were like you need
therapy and I'm like okay let's get
there let's get therapy what do I do
right so I get the [ __ ] so I get the
the the info on the therapy I don't know
how I don't remember how but then I go
to I get the info and I got to go to
this place and like Pasadena or like
even past pasady
and that's where I used to go to actual
therapy for real me when I was trying to
figure out my [ __ ] just got more crazy
but
so I go to I go to the place and it's
like a huge office building and and
there's like it's not it's not it's not
just for me it's like a therapy for like
a class and I'm like oh well what is
this and they're like well you just sit
down and you'll see and we sat there and
we watched I'm actually realizing that
it's just like the one I'm the dream I
made up four minutes ago I didn't mean
to but and we're watching a movie and
there's like girls there in the in the
class and also other guys but like the
girls are like really like hitting on me
like so far this is the least terrifying
dream of all time this is just awesome
but and they're like hey I'm you know
I'm 21 like we you know like you see we
should hang out after this and I'm like
I don't think so you know like I'm 37
like this is what I'm saying in the
dream I'm like I don't know you know
because I felt weird I felt like people
were like trying to get something from
me right and and so one of the chicks
there was like I know you not not as if
I wasn't like necessarily somebody with
fans I was like she's like knew me from
something else like we met once or knew
somebody knew me through another person
I probably wronged so so we watch this
movie and it's like this movie and I'm
the whole time I'm looking around like
what the [ __ ] is going on I don't
understand what this this is not therapy
right so I'm like maybe after the movie
then we break off and then I get to have
therapy okay but the movies so long that
I end up leaving okay
and I leave and then I I hit the
elevator and I got in the elevator I go
down to this garage level and I walk
outside
and I'm in this garage like you know
there's a this office building garage
thing with like a lot of spaces and it's
pretty empty and I say hey man how the
[ __ ] does this Asian guy walks up really
nice-looking Asian man and
and he's and I was like hey man how the
[ __ ] do I get out of here what's the
deal and he was said and he slips and he
says oh you you uh you were here with
the cult right and I was like uh oh and
then I realized that they were trying to
[ __ ] and recruit me for a cult and you
know what dude
I swear to God in my dream it felt good
to be wanted and I'm not making that up
in my dream I was like dude this feels
right I'm not trying to be funny I I
think it is funny
but I'm telling you the truth and I was
like yeah but I said I still think just
based on principle I gotta get out of
here even though it felt right to be
there
so I was like here's like I'll open the
garage for you so the garage opens up
and I go out and then there's another
dude on a motorcycle and he's like hey
man you just got to get out that way and
go out that way but hope to see you soon
they were nice enough about it let me
leave and [ __ ] but then I woke up and I
was like you know what dude cult say
that they they get a bad rap they get a
bad rap but but this one doesn't the
congratulations it's not a bad we're
just we're chillin I would we're trying
to get [ __ ] and sucked man this is
hedonism we're out in a log cabin
feeling grass man that's all it is when
I try to [ __ ] say the end is near I
mean maybe it is but whatever we're
trying to get [ __ ] inside yeah so so
that was my dream and I don't know if it
was interesting or not but I think it
pertains to us babies I think it
pertains to us my babies yeah they gotta
you feel accepted though you know that's
the thing and then they just turn on you
on a [ __ ] dime right there just like
everybody's beautiful we're all in this
raw we're all one if you just be and
then all of a sudden they're like by the
way [ __ ] jump off a building and
you're like what what for the cult we
love you go you're like okay that's
hitting a car and then the car alarm
going off you know that there's the
thing when when in the mood in the
what's that ice cube or he's like [ __ ]
car alarms I always thought he said
actually wait hold on I think it's one
fire that said this [ __ ] car alarms and
and they were trying to find out who the
[ __ ] car alarms was have a what are your
[ __ ] you could tweet me what are your
favorite what are your most [ __ ] up
lyrics that you thought that that were
actual lyrics that stupid [ __ ] one
about the Tony Danza
tiny dancer one right isn't that in a
movie or something I don't know anyway
um dude III I know this was a week ago
this was over a week ago but look at
that one we built this city on sausage
rolls I mean come on dude sausage rolls
nobody thought that fat piggies thought
that oh I like that thought oh oh I like
that song I Wanna that one I've heard
before I excuse me while I kissed this
guy well soon when I kissed this guy
anyway
so this happened a week ago the Fergie
thing where I was talking about it
online now I did a video of it it's on
Instagram and I put it on YouTube about
like Fergie like this is what we expect
this is what we should have gotten I
thought she [ __ ] you know killed it
because she took a risk and like [ __ ]
you guys for being
and people were like on the Instagram
story they got it cuz it was me saying
it but I tweeted it also not the video
just the words and people were like what
the [ __ ] bro you make fun of everything
and now you're trying to tell us we
can't make fun of Fergie no let me tell
you something right now no what I'm
saying is you're being a [ __ ] CUDA
just making fun of [ __ ] because other
people are making fun of it I'm making
fun of you
okay it was her rendition of whatever it
was the star-spangled banner was was at
at worst bad but come on dude she she
did it in her fergie way what the [ __ ]
did you think was gonna happen dude
that's the thing if you she you got
Ferdie to do it you got her to do it
that's like when Michael Jordan played
baseball what the [ __ ] did you expect
you [ __ ] make fun of him sure but
like don't I mean dude and then and she
apologized dude that was so wrong [ __ ]
that I wish I sang the star-spangled
banner badly by mistake I would have
said hey everyone in the everyone who's
got a problem with my star-spangled
banner' [ __ ] rub the front of your nose
against my taint put your head down
let me squat I mean get the [ __ ] out of
here do it you're being a CUDA you can't
just [ __ ] make fun of some [ __ ] just
because everyone else is making fun of
it you're a coda hey get in the [ __ ]
wagon get in the wagon you CUDA you
ain't [ __ ] B somebody making up your
[ __ ] [ __ ] come up with your own okay
fine oh yeah it was bad all fine but due
to and and this is her fault for
apologizing but to force somebody to
apologize get the [ __ ] out of here
everybody wants an apology dude you know
what lay
down put the back of your head on the
ground lemme squat fum fum fum fum fum
fum that's what I want your [ __ ] mouth
to be doing on my taint
I don't want it but you deserve it dude
it's so annoying and then people and
then people were like oh you're trying
to get laid you're trying to [ __ ] Fergie
huh hey what yeah dude yeah I'm trying
to have sex with Fergie that's why I
said stop making fun of her yeah [ __ ]
CUDA huh
what oh dude it was so dumb I was like
oh yeah maybe if you took more risks you
wouldn't be sitting at a cubicle every
day and people were like I work at a
cubicle I go to pay to see you shut up
shut up you're offended I don't give a
[ __ ] shut up dude it does yeah oh I'm
saying everybody that works at a cubicle
is a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] no I'm
obviously not saying that and obviously
there's extent there's there's there's a
situations where you got it dude here's
the other thing too many people live out
their [ __ ] goddamn dreams Hey Dude if
you have kids and you're 40 don't try
and be a rapper take care of your kids
get a job with benefits
put down the [ __ ] microphone
you got sponsibility 'he's obviously
there's it's a case-by-case basis
there's too many people out there trying
to be a goddamn poet ah you're not a
poet go to work but it's like dude I I
do I have to say everything no fill in
the [ __ ] blanks dude I'm not writing
a novel I'm writing a screenplay there's
a lot of white on that paper
[ __ ] fill it in
everybody wants to [ __ ] up they want
an apology dude and that's what's
[ __ ] up the world and we know that
now I dude it's like we're starting art
is starting to get [ __ ] because of
apologies oh well we got to make it
better let's make a movie that makes
everything okay what dude chuttan
make a movie you want to make don't do
it's like the it's like oh you know when
you hire someone as an actor in a movie
it should be the best person for the job
it you know I'm not saying hey if you're
a [ __ ] I'm like also you can make any
movie you want to make you can make any
movie you want to make these are
companies that make any movie they want
to make you know make Black Panther you
wanna make Black Panther that's awesome
that's great culturally it's relevant
and that's a [ __ ] good thing to do
and you know you're out there making
celebrating you know African culture
whatever the [ __ ] well African culture
whatever you want to do that's great you
make the movie good you get to do it you
get to do it people go see it great you
make money [ __ ] awesome okay good
good for everyone people are getting mad
at giving backlash to Jared Leto for
playing a Yakuza or some [ __ ] like a
white guy who who goes into it goes to
Japan and starts playing and making it
they can make that movie they want to
make that movie they can make that movie
if they want to make that movie it's a
business dude it's a [ __ ] business
is it wrong you know whatever should
they make movies about with more
Japanese people than I'm you know yeah
but like it's not it's not it's it's I
don't know I I guess I don't know enough
about that situation to here I go again
talking out of turn I'm just one of you
guys dude it's just so it's like oh okay
alright so here's another here's another
example the the trans acting thing where
it's like oh that didn't Jared Leto
played it in the [ __ ] what's it
called in
the movie with Matthew McConaughey where
he redoes the scene where he's crying
for 7 minutes Dallas buyers club people
are mad when oh but he's not trans so
why is he playing trans what what if
what if
first of all Jared Leto is a star people
gonna go see a movie for Jared Leto okay
no I granted there aren't many you know
trans actors that are stars and I
understand that that's because the
opportunities weren't afforded to them
but not many movies are made about trans
people more now than ever probably but
you know if you want to get Jared Leto
for a part you get Jared Leto for a part
because people are going to see a movie
because it's Jared Leto if Aegis Elba
wants to play a trans guy he's gonna get
a lot of backlash but people are going
to go see a movie because it's a Juris
Alba I don't know I don't think I'm on
the I don't know
it's just
sky for the part get the best guy for
the [ __ ] part if that guy happens to
be trans and used that guy but then
there is that whole thing about how oh
yeah they haven't had the opportunities
and this and that I get it but if you're
if you're if you're a trans actor
playing trans parts you're not good you
know there aren't that many parts you
know it's hard to you know it's hard to
become a star with a fanbase that then
is a draw because of that because there
aren't that many movies like that but
only recently has it even been accepted
and it's still not accepted in a lot of
part of the world you know whatever
I don't know I'm [ __ ] kind of
trailing off but I think you get my
point
uh it's like it's like if an actor what
was the other one a Matt Bomer I think
was gonna play a trans person and I
think that they like all these groups
like petition for him to not be it and I
don't even know if they're making the
movie anymore what if they wanted a
masculine guy and and and it was and
they wanted him to be as masculine as
Matt Bomer
and there wasn't and and and the other
people that they were and Matt Palmer's
a star I did whatever the the argument
ends when when when you're like all the
guy's a star alone and people are gonna
go see them all because of that anyway
what was I [ __ ] going to talk about
it was something in there I was gonna
talk about oh yeah oh yeah that was the
thing I was trying to talk about this is
Fergie backlash
people were just [ __ ] mad dude and I
here's the other thing too Chris Rock
was talking it as special about how the
prop mate the main problem with
everybody's relationship is they stop
[ __ ] because if you're in the
beginning that those problems that you
have now
you had them in the beginning you were
just [ __ ] and and and not dealing
with the problems which is hilarious
it's a [ __ ] really funny bit but I
think that that pertains to also people
are getting mad about [ __ ] because they
have nothing to do there
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] jobs or their with
their family and they don't want to
[ __ ] be there and so or their life or
even worse their life is boring as [ __ ]
they don't they're not only they don't
even live in the city they want to live
in so they're online living vicariously
through all this other [ __ ] and they're
like you know what that's right this is
wrong I'm gonna tweet about it and
you're not even [ __ ] actually mad
about it
you're just [ __ ] saying stuff you're
literally saying blah blah blah blah and
then sometimes it becomes a movement and
it ends careers whatever it is you know
I don't know but it's uh but that Fergie
thing was just like oh Jesus Christ come
on it's interesting to to see how
quickly these things go away like like
oh by the way I'm not talking about the
me to think that that thing is real and
that was horrible that is horrible the
the what what these women have been
through that's [ __ ] awful that's not
one of the movements I was [ __ ]
talking about but um like these things
go away like like which is which is like
like there was a guy oh yeah it was
David Copperfield like they somebody was
saying like oh he he got he groped or
something or something a few one or two
women and from one day and then everyone
forgot about it and that's that's not
good either if that's real like that
that's but they it goes away the David
Connolly keep something team model after
impassioned plea not to be judged it's
weird that uh that that these things
will come out in one day and then go
away the next day
although when bigger news happens it's
how it does
like it's a [ __ ] like that school
shooting took over everything you know
God
alright I'm drilling off here let me do
a [ __ ] ad and then I'll and then I'll
get back into it
there we go here we go mm square cache
if you haven't heard we are one fire one
fart too and I switching over the cash
app it's the simplest way to pay people
back friends family
very thoughtful wedding guests frogs
with suits on anyone really sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly into your bank account in just
a few seconds and the cash up lets you
do way more than that now you can even
buy and sell Bitcoin instantly so get on
the Bitcoin train get your paycheck
deposited right into the app pull money
out of the ATM with the free custom cash
card or use it to spend anywhere you
like you really won't find a more useful
finance app out there and of course when
you download the cash app five dollars
goes to you and five dollars goes to
time's up Legal Defense Fund and that's
a good thing and we support that times
up legal defense fund because it's it's
the right thing to do and so if you
download the free cash app or iOS for
iOS or Android now then it's one step
closer to being a true baby as well
because we all use it over here it's
great I use it to pay people back all
the time and I use it to to make money
too I make people pay me on their
tripping tripping sounds like a white
guy talking about rapping but tripping
if you look it is a great company you
ever plan a vacation finding a place to
stay that'll make everyone happy for the
right price we're all you want to visit
I mean if it was like a full-time job
trying to do this right you're trying to
go relax but you can't because you find
by the time you find everything out
you're all stressed out
I hate doing that having to figure it
all out because it's it's it it makes
you a ball of stress in the whole point
in going on vacation is to relax spend
less time planning your next trip with
TripIt calm don't visit a ton of
different sites on tripping calm
onesearch lets you compare every home
from the world's top vacation rental
sites in one place to find the best deal
on your perfect vacation rental now I
should have I should stop right there
because that is enough for you guys to
go do that but for some of you dummies
let me speak on it a little bit more
tripping calm you can join the millions
of travelers who find more savings with
rates up to eighty percent less than
traditional hotel rooms and it's better
they did the work for you here if you're
planning Spring Break on the beach in
Florida tripping calm can't wait to swim
in Lake Tahoe for the summer tripping
calm all of them anywhere you want to go
sitting on the deck of a smother of a
Smoky Mountains cabin that's my next one
tripping calm this year save time and
money when you book the vacation home of
your dreams with tripping calm slash
Congrats that's tripping calm slash
Congrats find your perfect vacation run
rental tripping dot-com slash Congrats I
was going through Instagram the other
day I got in one of these warm one of
these rabbit holes and just kind of like
clicked on a photo of this chick that
was like had the hot body and all that
[ __ ] and the fake lips and she had like
9 million followers or something and I I
love looking at this [ __ ] because like
this one said hey like the it's like the
top the her bio was like recording
artist and it's like stop you do porn
it's all good but you do porn I
talking to this person once a long time
ago and she was trying to describe to me
about this girl that she met and she's
like I met this porn I met this porno
actress and I was like whoo and she's
like I forget her name and she's like I
remember and she googled her and and she
showed me her Instagram and I was like
oh I was like I don't does she do porn
and she was like well yeah look and she
showed me her Instagram and I was like I
don't think she does actual porn does
she and she was like well what would you
call this and she just actually didn't
wasn't joking she was like well this is
porn and I was like dude that's so funny
that like she I was like you're right
like she's up she's basically a porn
actress and that's fine but like she
like you don't like that's what you are
you you you porn actress you're not a
recording artist heed the porn and it
made me laugh and then I started
thinking about it these profiles are
just like let me just
dude I'm steady this is an announcement
here if you've got millions and millions
of followers and you're showing your
tits and ass most of your followers are
guys okay it is a blanket statement but
most of your followers are guys now I'm
talking about 90 to 95 percent at least
of your followers are guys therefore
you're you're not marketing the people
think oh these people have millions of
followers are making millions of dollars
you're not marketing towards women and
you're certainly not trying to sell
motorcycles to men or like baseball
gloves or whatever the [ __ ] men like
okay so you're making your money [ __ ]
if you don't have a job an actual job
where you clock in and clock out and you
make
money if you don't have a [ __ ] album
if you don't have a podcast if you don't
have a [ __ ] your Europe
I want you these are hookers these are
people if they're flying all around the
world they're not models and they're
just doing their own photoshoots is
their most likely making money [ __ ]
guys and and and here's the thing that's
not I don't even give a [ __ ] if some if
you want to make money [ __ ] guys or a
prostitution that's do it I don't give a
[ __ ] who cares I don't judge what I
can't stand is somebody pretending
something that they're not okay that's
what I can't stand you don't you don't
get to like it's like it's like you
don't get injections in your ass and
[ __ ] and and and and the tummy tucks
and [ __ ] and B and then tout fitness
that's [ __ ] up and it [ __ ] up other
people trying to do what they're trying
to do and they think that they could
[ __ ] do it and I can't do it cuz you
got fat injected yes but so so these
young girls or whatever are seeing these
other women with 10 million followers
they're trying to get followers and they
think oh I'm gonna [ __ ] be rich like
these people but the reason why these
girls have money is because they're
[ __ ] 65 year old men on yachts that's
why they have money you're not [ __ ]
marketing what are they who are they
marketing some of these some of these
Instagram models they they're they're
selling detox tea they're pretending
that they have deals the who's buying
detox tea men know women who if you have
10 million followers and you're showing
your tits and your [ __ ] men are
following you not women men are
following you so if 5% of your followers
are women out of out of 10 million you
do
you do the [ __ ] math so so who's
paying detox tea is paying for this [ __ ]
no you know who's paying for it the guy
inside you the guy's squirting inside
you the guy squirting inside you on a
patio on a veranda that's who's paying
for you the guy's squirting inside jhana
veranda and I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're making money hand over [ __ ]
dick I don't give a [ __ ] do it get that
money but don't say you're a [ __ ]
recording artist because you're not
making money being a recording artist
you're making money getting squirted
inside you and Anya and Enya now I get
it
you don't have to be like hey I'm a
hooker here are my rates on Instagram
because that's gross as [ __ ] to
nine-year-olds following you but don't
say you're a [ __ ] magician Kay just
so weird man like think about it and
then these idiots are like aw man one
ticket for inside your [ __ ] you know
these like Persian dudes and [ __ ] uh
I would love to play press play on your
[ __ ] BB
these idiots you know or whoever the
[ __ ] like are so beautiful some guy in
Minnesota so beautiful most beautiful
woman in the world and no yo dude come
on love your music or some [ __ ] no come
on man shut the [ __ ] up you see you're
not talk about want to get laid on
online dude just like your I I want to
say you're not fooling anybody but you
are fooling people that's the thing
whose fault is it is it their fault or
is the [ __ ] idiots following them
fault that's that's what I don't know
that's what I can't figure out myself
it's it's it's a little bit of both but
I think ultimately it comes down to the
person doing it I I always think it
comes down to the person doing it like
like that you have some sort of a
responsibility for the human race like
these a lot of these comedy videos are
just so bad on Instagram and and I want
to be like who are these
idiots that like this [ __ ] but it's it
all comes down to the person making it
dude it all comes down to the person
making it try harder try harder if
you're gonna make a well produced video
for laughs try harder unless you're just
gonna [ __ ] run and gun it like you
know i don't i don't use lighting on my
[ __ ] i I don't I think Instagram is
corny like that if you [ __ ] like do
shoots for it and all that [ __ ] but like
for me I'll be like oh that's funny and
I'll record it and then [ __ ] put it
on and I think it's funny but I didn't
even it's like you just try to do just
did it quickly if you like it great if
not fine but this is what social media
is for me it's not me it's not my source
income you know it's to grow the the
cult and streamline this [ __ ] the
baby [ __ ] yeah man I just like make no
mistake these girlies women who have 10
million followers on Instagram and no
job make no mistake they are hookers
that's it case closed that's it there's
no beyond that they [ __ ] for paper
there's no beyond that oh you are you
made a music video that's cool but you
make money hookin uh yeah unless you got
like you [ __ ] start you know like
that like you know who you know was a
good example of [ __ ] make it she has
a business now is that that Lexy
Panterra girl who was twerking and [ __ ]
and everyone follow her cuz her ass was
moving she I think she did but I bet she
I think she had a business before that
like a dance like she's obviously a
professor she's good at date she's good
at something she's good at dancing and
now she's coming out with music and [ __ ]
and whatever you know it's like I can't
tell the difference between good music
and bad music anymore anyway when it
comes to pop so you know sounds
professional to me but but uh
you know she but it's funny though
because when you get known for something
which she got known for shaking her ass
mmm
people like I looked at one of her music
videos this is not what I was talking
about by the way
that's her but this is not what I was
talking about originally she like I
looked at her YouTube channel and [ __ ]
in all the comments like some [ __ ]
or just like came here to watch it shake
your ass you into it like get like how
[ __ ] sad can you be guy like just
come on to it like a little bit like I
don't know twerk twerking millions of
[ __ ] hits from twerking at least you
can do it you can do something though
it's like I don't know
I got an argument with my dad the other
day not an actual argument we get and my
family is uh my family is we get and all
we do is get into dumb and silly
arguments like and we love it we have
fun doing it and I have an uncle here's
here's what it's like I have my dad and
then I have an uncle Vinny which I
actually have an uncle Vinny from New
Jersey you know and then I have an uncle
Richard and all we do is so my uncle
Vinny has two [ __ ] wallets he's crazy
the he has two wallets he has one for
singles and one for the other money and
I was like why do you have two wallets
and he's like because if I need to get
singles I just grab in this side but if
I need bigger bills I grab on this side
and I'm like oh well just put them
together it's way less work you'll have
to sit on two [ __ ] wallets and he was
like he's like if I need to tip I just
go into this wallet it was and then uh
what was the thing that he said though
he's got two wallets I can't remember
the funny part which is why I started
talking about and now I forgot forget it
Jesus Christ anyway we get into he's
crazy he's like he's he he got to he
buys everything from infomercials like
everything
like he gets this he gets this digest
that it's good for digestion like these
drinks like they're like I don't know
what they're called but he drinks him
cuz he over eats and he's like this way
I can eat whatever I want and then drink
one of these and I feel okay and my
dad's like why don't you just [ __ ]
not overeat and he was like well yeah I
mean I could do that but also I could
just also eat and then drink this and I
feel fine and my dad's like alright let
me try one of those and he tried one and
my dad's like I don't feel I don't feel
any different you know and my uncle
Vinny is like cuz you didn't [ __ ]
overeat like this these are the
conversations to get into like that's
the argument and my dad's like yeah
because you're not supposed to [ __ ]
overeat look that's like a typical
conversation if we're all together so he
so my dad was talking about I I said I
called him up or whenever I say
bald-faced liar I I don't know if it's
bald-faced liar or bold-faced liar so I
[ __ ] so I I always do them I marry
the two I say bald-faced liar
we can't tell i'm also from the east
coast cuz maybe I'm just saying bald
face like bald face or maybe one same
old face like a West Coast dude and I'm
saying bold face right cuz I I'm East
Coast for him but West Coast raised just
like Tupac so so we were talking and I
said well he said nah my dad said no
it's it's behind remember which one he
was saying it was but he was like it's
bald-faced liar and I was like which one
and he was like let me google it and he
googled it and he starts reading it like
and this article dude the I don't
remember what the [ __ ] I'm gonna here it
is I told her to text it to me
link is it bald-faced or bold-faced lie
so it's on Mental Floss calm and my
dad's reading this and he reads me this
like it's like he's right this is what
no no listen to how we were confused
before him but listen to this listen to
how this is maybe the more
confusing thing I've ever I've never had
an explanation that made you more
confused than this
okay there is often confusion about
which word bald or bold is the correct
one in this particular idiom but fret no
more we now have the definitive answer
they're both acceptable okay now I don't
I don't know first of all no it's one or
the other because it's not what's
acceptable its who made it and who set
it at first one fired two with the COFF
but who who made it up
is what it is it's like all of a sudden
people start calling people coda instead
of CUDA well they both except no it's
CUDA okay okay most sources agree that
the original expression coined in the
late 1600s listen how [ __ ] convoluted
and confusing this gets was actually
barefaced lie so first of all it's
something that has nothing to do with
it's a whole nother word okay barefaced
lie now at the time check this out dude
we were crying laughing so hard I was I
was so mad at my dad cuz he was trying
to act like this was this was in support
for him at the time bear meant brazen or
bold okay so all right let me just keep
reading so the late 60s was actually
barefaced lie at the time bear meant
brazen or bold at that time in history
almost all men sported a full set of
whiskers and it was considered quite
daring or even audacious for a male to
be clean shaven or barefaced
eventually the word for hairless went
from bear to bald and so did the
description of a blatant fib okay all
right
are you listening to this dude boldface
is now considered acceptable as well
since bold has the same meaning as bear
originally did dude this is so confusing
this is an explaining [ __ ] also it can
technically refer to a falsehood that
appears in print at a in a bold typeface
dude come
on the easiest way out of this maze of
idioms obviously is to simply tell the
truth at all times
dude all right so look come on the
confusion bold or bold so here's the
deal
it is bold this is what it's basically
saying it is bold to have a bare face
which is bald that's what this is saying
in the sixteen hundreds it was if you
were bare faced I'm legitimately [ __ ]
this is like Inception this is like the
moment where Leonardo DiCaprio and his
[ __ ] guys are falling off the bridge
in the car and it's all civil emotion
you're like whoa bear face bald face
bold its bold to be bald oh [ __ ] my ass
dude
are you [ __ ] me I'm never I said
this is how we ended the conversation
I'm never saying it again I'm saying
you're a liar you lied to my face I
would never I will never say bold-faced
lie or bald-faced lie ever [ __ ] again
because [ __ ] this [ __ ] dude and it's all
your own fault it's all your it's all
your fault if you like that expression
your [ __ ] never say it again
we as true babies we don't say that [ __ ]
it's too confusing what is it this is
the [ __ ] that matters do it
not the Fergie [ __ ] this is the [ __ ]
that matters this is how it got all
untethered
um anyway we got in that kind of a thing
my fate my whole family we were all like
that that's how we show love is to get
into the arguments like that it's it's
literally some of my happiest times
quite literally I'm I'm happiest when
I'm doing that with my family and I've
been in relationships before where the
the girl doesn't get that and they come
from like I've dated a girl a long time
ago where anytime her family was arguing
it was like the worst thing in her life
which you know is horrible if you grow
up like that but but whenever we would
do that she would have like this PTSD
[ __ ] and she was like she was like get
bummed out and it's and it sucked
because of like a fundamental difference
between the two of us and we could and
and she was just like I don't know I
mean that didn't ultimately lead to us
breaking up but it was just like a red
flag because like I loved doing that man
arguing is my favorite but in a fun way
I hate doing it in a real way but like
that's all we do
my dad dude every time he's gonna be 70
and every time we have the birthdays
come around same time in March but he'll
he'll this is another thing we did he
said last night he was like I'm gonna be
71 and I'm and I say what do you know
you're gonna be 70 and he says nah but
listen when you're zero and you're born
that's your first year of life so you're
1 and then when you're 1 you're - so I'm
gonna be 71 technically and he does it
every [ __ ] year and I say dad I know
I know that I know that I'm not
disagreeing with you
but you say it all the time and it's
corny as [ __ ] and and what do you want
me to do when you say that I agree with
you and he says but people but that's
not what we are you know but we're
Wawona
a one year older than we all are and I
say okay all right man what the [ __ ] do
you
what to do about it now and he says okay
well just saying you're a 1 year older
and and and and he does it everything
and my mom's like does this every year
he he doesn't do it every year he does
it he does it every time there's a
[ __ ] birthday around I'm not six it
doesn't entertain me
but what does entertain me is grilling
him about it monk has got to waltz what
a [ __ ] you up to wallets it's way
easier he says cuz you got my dollar
bills in one if I need to tip somebody I
said what if you want need to go to
[ __ ] titty bar he says why I haven't
been there in 30 years I said to put the
[ __ ] dollar bills in you one pocket
um
what's another one we would get into oh
man and then the more kids the people
have the more the more the conversation
becomes like now I got a cousin who he's
like [ __ ] 23 now my uncle Richard's
son there was my cousin and now he's
involved in the [ __ ] arguments
oh we it's great ah man one time my dad
we were playing [ __ ] this was when the
hell was this a long time ago we were
playing what's that [ __ ] game where
you put the phone up to the thing and
heads up yeah and wanna hire we don't
even one fire um and it was magician and
my dad didn't know what to say so he
just goes comes like this you gonna have
to see it on the video but it goes like
this
uh-uh and he goes and dude we cried
laughing for um a week I mean dude the
game was over after that he goes uh that
was his [ __ ] pressed oh [ __ ] as a
musician's musician magician and hey by
the way man musician and magician change
it call it something else it's too close
but dude we [ __ ] were laughing dude
and then in that same game he he tripped
and fell and hurt himself and dude
we how god Annalise is so funny when
somebody falls in hurts himself man one
time I was in high school and this girl
she was so hot I was such was so hot but
she was one of those girls that was not
popular but like you know that girl God
that girl is amazing in high school the
girl that's like super beautiful but not
popular and the and you're in high
school and you're like why is she not
the most popular girl and you're like I
can't be the only does anybody notice
she's taller than air what's the deal
with how come she's got the long flowy
hair
you guys don't and the jeans look good
what's the deal with the and everyone's
just like yeah but she gets A's you're
like yeah but she's alright and they
just let her go or walk around no and no
no just on [ __ ] every all the high
school kids well wasn't it and then and
then she comes back and then you go away
to college and you come back and she
comes back and you're like hey you see
and you're like I knew [ __ ] I
knew it man
you let her go on [ __ ] and now she's
got the [ __ ] studly estoy friend in
college and we all [ __ ] up dude you
could have married her right so I saw
her man what was her name I remember I
tried to look her up afterwards she was
like 2 years younger than me maybe I
don't remember her name at all but she
was running first of all if you're in
high school and you run anywhere you're
a [ __ ] dork and that sucks cuz I
always want to get where I'm going quick
but don't run did I got a buddy you have
that buddy while I'm going off crazy
here but my buddy Ian Edwards took me to
the comedian who's hilarious check him
out
I can't even imagine this [ __ ]
running this guy walks only I swear to
god somebody could be chasing him with a
machete
and he would be like
if it's my time it's my time but this
guy walks when he's in trouble when he's
in I mean also he people who end up
walking a lot though they never get in
trouble though man right anyway they're
just cuz it's like that is the attitude
that they exude that surrounds them and
I am running for [ __ ] anyway so so she
was running which is probably why
everyone just let her go around all on
[ __ ] dirt and [ __ ] you know in high
school but but she was uh running around
running around and she was running
towards for lunch like going to the car
and she [ __ ] fell hard and she it was
holding a lunch box too I mean she was
like a junior I don't know why she's
holding a lunch box but maybe was like
to be ironic or cute or maybe it was one
of the reasons why she wasn't popular
she's running holding a lunch box you
know and she fell and like skinned
durniak enough and I wanted to laugh
because it's so funny when people fall
but she she just he did the thing this
was way before Family Guy when she was
just ah you know what I'm talking about
the [ __ ] or Peter Griffin does that
and she just out out she couldn't help
it but she's around too many people but
she couldn't help it and I didn't help
her and I'm bad I should have helped her
but I didn't want to help her cuz I
didn't want her to think that I was
trying to like do her you know how weird
is life there's all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's going on in your head
that stops you from being a good person
or a bad person and you're not even
doing what you want to do how weird his
life I didn't help her because I didn't
wanna look like I don't want to [ __ ] her
like I look like I wanted to [ __ ] her
I'd be like I she could do it she's
probably not too hurt I'm just gonna be
a good guy and not help her
with everything so she fell I don't know
why I started talking about falling but
uh anyway okay we're at we're getting
there so I'm gonna do I'm gonna do I
think I have a good most [ __ ] up in
let me look let me look at this cuz I
think I have a good most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week I yep
oh wow I got a good one there's one of
the best you guys ready for the most
[ __ ] up Instagram post Italy alright
you guys this is one of the best ones
ever and I saved this and I went oh
alright this is a picture of a guy it's
a selfie he's got his [ __ ] earphones
in and he's wearing sunglasses and a
scarf and a really high jacket with the
collar so and sunglasses and this we've
got a fresh cut and therefore he's super
cool this is the comment oh and the
sun's peeking in it's a it the sun's
peeking in over his face it looks like
very cinematic this filter is caught
this what it says this filter is called
rise as of 2018 that's all I have done
risen
to the occasion showed up put in the
work and continued to rise above all
obstacles and difficulties crazy how
when this photo was taken on a sunny day
last week the rays from the Sun were
shining ever so perfectly into the photo
as if to say conquer today huh and
that's exactly what I did every day is
yours to conquer and seek how you so
desire he doesn't talk like this that's
the best part
seek how you so desire a young Game of
Thrones you fuckboy the question is what
are you willing to sacrifice and how
hard are you willing to work for it ah
oh of course now went to historic town
and of course he works out all the time
had no idea but he does unbelievable
unbelievable unbelievable dude
unbelievable so boring to be like that
you know [ __ ] things
me want to go ah you know that old C&C
Music Factory song things that make it
go boom I got things that make you go ah
things that make you go gonna make ya
till you bleed is that dope enough
indeed let's go to Twitter questions
Alexis Arabia Emily read it to chaski
get him married how do you feel about
that yeah man well here's how I feel
about it now I I actually didn't realize
how much I've talked about her on the
podcast until she got engaged or did she
get married or engaged she got married
huh um and then people were like oh no
Chris Lea your heart broke and I was
like what and then I was like I guess
I've talked about her a lot but that's
just like I think I just talk about it
because I don't know how to pronounce
your last name and I'm not gonna learn
and so therefore she is Emily ready to
chomsky but yeah and then I looked into
it and I saw the guy that he she married
Hey oh she married [ __ ] snow in
Farmer you know say let me say I can
play I'm a little um down I think the -
I sell it I'm sorry Sam someone Alain
Chomsky Ian farmer remember that song so
many of you don't in farmer you know
said let me say I can play em I let him
down attack the - I said let me sell
myself someone on LAN I let you down and
then and then people would be like you
know what that songs about he stabbed
someone once and he's admitting it but
he's doing it in in reggae so you don't
know ah things that make you go come on
dude
nothing is more [ __ ] 12 year old New
Jersey than being like you know what
that songs about he stabbed someone and
he's admitting it but he didn't want the
cops to find out so he sang it in reggae
in you know same lamp like you slow it
down is gonna be like I stabbed someone
in the alley
YUM I stepped someone in in LA don't
tell anyone the case isn't closed you
know say Yakima am I like keeping down
the dictum and says anyway
ready to chow ski merry snow and the guy
has a blonde beard and really dope he
looks like he'd be in color me bad the
update he looks like he'd be in a reboot
of Color Me badd and you know maybe he's
the sexiest guy in the world I don't
know I haven't matter maybe when you
meet him he's just like nah nah like no
matter what you suggest he's just like
nah and you're like aw god damn I gotta
suck that guy's dick you know but he he
he his face is the same color is his his
face is blonde you know I mean when you
have a blond face you're either you're
either girls either think you're so ugly
or you're the sexiest guy they've ever
seen
oh you got it if you have a blonde face
just go like this a lot nah and you will
squirt so much he got Emily credit to
chow ski now they were dating for three
weeks and then got married this is what
I learned not gonna work out
it made me bummed though because like
don't get married after three weeks it's
sad
you're just gonna get gonna get divorced
soon you know I'm gonna get that voice
getting annulled
but it's just like I don't know we're
all lost anyway so [ __ ] it I was married
and divorced but I didn't get married
after three weeks I got married after
two years and then broke up got divorced
two years later and then I was like
infant you know say I come too am i
licking boom I'm down that part I like
him down you know he stabbed somebody oh
yeah cool even as an 11 year old I was
like oh yeah nice cool yeah arrest him
also there's all these rappers talking
about yo I [ __ ] killed that
[ __ ] arrest that guy the snow's
not even [ __ ] doing it full out with
rap he's doing it with reggae he's like
not even really saying it uh say yeah
yeah dude it's just you know you can't
get married after three weeks of knowing
somebody because it's 2018 you can only
get married three weeks in if it's 1930
yeah be like oh yeah my grandpa met her
you everyone knows the story yeah my
friend's grandpa I met her grant met met
the grandma yeah and three days later
they got engaged and then a week later
they got married
what really yeah when Oh April 12 1904
you're like oh yeah
times were different back then [ __ ]
women could barely vote and also there
was slavery it was much different it was
the tea it was the most ah time of all
time uh have you seen this [ __ ] Benny
Hinn guy Colin McDonald tweeted me will
you be blessing babies into the cult
Benny Hinn style at your show is hoping
for a Boston date I'd be really funny I
am gonna come to Boston it'll be in the
it'll be in the fall but I haven't
posted it or solidified it yet but um
yeah man this guy Benny Hinn rappin
people with his blazer whapping just
[ __ ] taking the Blazer and whapping
people and then the guy in the red shirt
that dude just gettin [ __ ] nailed and
then just made a falling down so
unnecessary all of this [ __ ] look the
guy the red was the best the guy in the
red is the best Wow
it makes it even funnier that hold on it
makes it even funnier that I think he's
the only black guy right is he black
yeah that's the best cuz he's like aw
man got fit in with these white folks
maybe he's not maybe just other either
way I like to imagine him is the only
black guy that's like I do with these
white [ __ ] are doing Wow
we could wrap it up huh what all right
right right uh Warren higher okay here
we go we have this is the elder right
okay we have a new elder I didn't know
what this guy was doing I thought it was
weird but then I'm just looking at it at
first I was like what is this guy doing
but then I realized how awesome it was
this is a real baby spreading the word
of congratulations on his own time and
his own dime now we never suggest people
need to put their money into the cult
you want to do that that's your own
thing but this guy went above and beyond
and he is an elder now Keith Richardson
at Keith's rich for 1:9 he's been a big
fan of true baby always asking questions
gaming the system this is this is the
thing that really got me though man
he'll he got a bunch of congratulations
congratulations stickers made by him
doing it had nothing to do with me
nothing do with me and mailed them out
to anyone who wanted them using his own
money and time he's spending to do this
so Thank You Keith we'll DM you with the
details and we'll get your certificate
and pin you are an elder of the cult and
and also you know I'm sure this is a
limited thing don't be all [ __ ]
hitting my passion for stickers now but
yeah man really cool put up a little
picture of it while he's watching my
special that guy Thank You Man thank you
for trying to spread this [ __ ] word
of this cult to the tweet reads after a
few hours in a really tired hair and I
finished getting the stickers ready to
send out expect to see them soon still
have plenty left so hit me up if you
want one there you go and also um let me
know if you get one tweet them to me I
want to see what they look like and
where your your sticker
you also get stickers of my [ __ ] if
you order anything online
on my on my site a sticker comes with it
but not that sticker so if you want that
sticker again you got it you got to hit
him up all right mm-hmm
square cache have you switched yet
download the free square cash app enter
the rewards code congrats get five
dollars get and give five dollars -
times up get it for iOS or Android now
you got to get my app the Chris D'Elia
app see some behind the scenes of the
podcast and also some of the [ __ ] on my
daily life Follow the Leader my new tour
buy tickets at Chris telecom Tallahassee
Florida Orlando Charleston Pittsburgh
Dayton Huntsville Nashville Denver Boise
Cleveland a lot of them are either sold
out or almost sold out
I know Denver is almost gone I think
there's a few tickets left a note for
Orlando and some of them are gone
go check though they're going I'm adding
like Red Bank New Jersey and I'm adding
a bunch of other ones I'm adding some
East Coast ones Delaware Baltimore I
think trying to get shot so I'm going to
those areas and then I'm adding Tulsa
and some other weird [ __ ] I just got to
emailed Tulsa and Dallas and OKC alright
and then mmm watch my [ __ ] on Netflix
and send me screenshots of pictures of
you watching it or whatever and then
that's about it I guess
hi mommy I think I might be able to good
dog I'm one more episode of the good
doctor biggest hi I'm not sure but video
YouTube video episode club whose days
are Wednesdays so thank for that and
then stuff has happened in babies you
guys are making this cult grow with our
numbers have been getting more and more
so I really appreciate you and I'll see
at a show but first alia conscious
thanks for listening